des yeux en forme b crew une lumière sur
la tête et un ventre balance voici
arthur le robot vérifie chaque midi ce
que jette les enfants de l'école
élémentaire des coudrais à maurepas
si ça faisait moins de 600 grammes et
bages pouvait appuyer sur un bouton pour
dire que que c'était le bon point c'est
que j'ai pas trop gaspiller semaine du
tueur et du coup il faut pas gâcher pour
rien parce qu'il ya des personnes qui
n'ont pas mangé
c'est important parce qu'il y en a qui
ont pas la chance comme un rejet par
tous comme ça installé il ya trois mois
le robot a été pensé par les agents de
la commune il est une nouvelle étape du
programme de lutte contre le gaspillage
alimentaires dans les cantines scolaires
et nous fait il ya un nom avec le
principe petites faims grande forme en
font calibre ses besoins calibre s'il a
vraiment faim si là il n'a il a moins
faim voire parfois s'ils aiment pas et
du coup il est au final quand il a
terminé de manger y jette évidemment
moins délaissé fcp des six ans il pas de
comprendre que je t'ai c'est pas bien et
que ça peut faire perdre des choses à
d'autres personnes qui sont dans le
besoin
le robot est calibré en fonction du menu
prévus chaque jour l'école continue
cette sensibilisation au gaspillage